tag 16 von putins ukraine befreiung
bitte ich darf noch angriffskrieg sagen
stimmt ich bin ja gar nicht in moskau im
gegensatz zu gerd schröder putins bester
gas vertreter besucht sein chef in der
zentrale die schlagzeile der woche wo er
wohl um frieden bittet heißt es und wer
weiß vielleicht sagt putin ja verkehrt
wenn ich geahnt hätte dass du auch gegen
den ukraine krieg bist dann wäre ich ja
niemals einmarschiert gerhard schröder
sage ich ihnen ist die perfekte wahl für
solche gespräche ernsthaft wer hat das
ohr so am kreml wie er sagt mir
irgendeinen russland experten der sich
besser auskennt meiner auffassung denkt
in der russischen führung keine darüber
nach die ukraine zu überfallen oder was
auch immer schlecht gealtert genau
wieder geehrt selber klar irgend eine
verhandlungslösung muss am ende kommen
was denn auch sonst man sollte sich nur
immer klar sein mit wem man darf
verhandelt und was man dem noch glauben
soll in der ukraine sind inzwischen
millionen auf der flucht bomben und
raketen fliegen mitten in wohngebiete
und allein im umzingelten mario pohl
sind hunderte zivilisten ums leben
gekommen darunter frauen und kinder oder
wie wladimir putin sagen würde
die militärische spezialaktion verläuft
streng nach plan
wenn bomben auf kinderkrankenhäuser der
plan waren dann läuft russland steht
wegen der sanktionen des westens kurz
vor der staatspleite und moralisch ist
putin sowieso bankrott sein eigenes volk
aber dass die ganze welt wird ihm nie
verzeihen was da gerade passiert warte
mal wo ist meine putin lusak
mrd ich darf doch leider sagen nein ok
vladi pass mal auf sieben der zehn
größten konzerne deines landes sind im
energie business du zerschießt der
gerade dein einziges geschäftsmodell für
immer noch mal genau so weiter dann ist
eine möchtegern supermacht bald eine
kolonie von china alter du bist völlig
isoliert und der erste mensch der welt
der vom papst und von konrad usern
öffentlich verurteilt worden verstehst
du du hast vorn haben sich aufgebracht
und die freuen sich sonst über jeden
[ __ ]
keine angst meine damen und herren
[ __ ] darf man sagen nur krieg halt
nicht jedenfalls nicht in russland
dessen nordkorea nie sierung
unaufhaltsam voranschreitet er ist ja
soo kim jong vladimir hat gerade ein
neues mediengesetz durch seinen witz
parlament gepeitscht das angebliche fake
news über die russische armee mit
gefängnis bedroht bis zu 15 jahre und
jetzt kommt auch für ausländische
journalistinnen und journalisten in
russland
das haben sie nicht immer die sowjets
getraut und es wirkt ein großer teil der
russen wehren sich jetzt nicht gegen die
politik putins gegen diesen kurs gegen
die ukraine ich muss meine worte
vorsichtig wählen sie wissen schon diese
unangenehme sache mit k die eventuell in
dem land mit gerade passiert jetzt
ausdrücklich kein vorwurf gegen die
kollegin natürlich nicht das zdf lässt
seine leute seit dieser woche auch nicht
mehr direkt aus moskau berichten in der
sicherheit einzelne kern meldung von
heute vielleicht bald wieder zurück
putin hat die letzten unabhängigen
russischen medien dichtgemacht twitter
und facebook geblockt warum macht er das
damit die russen seiner propaganda gar
nicht mehr entkommen können nicht mal im
kinderfernsehen der austria kabul niveau
craig known as am see
liegt
der
user
gekauft werde mir
zumindest der letzte satz stimmt sie
sahen einen ausschnitt aus den beliebten
russischen kindernachrichten logo
putin bemüht sich nicht mal mehr
demokratie wenigstens vorzutäuschen
meinungsfreiheit pressefreiheit alles
weg bis jetzt wurden schon über
10.000 mutige russen bei anti kriegs
demos verhaftet und während die ukraine
brennt trifft der alte kriegsverbrecher
zum weltfrauentag
ausgewählte flugbegleiterin und labert
sie voll mit seinen lügengeschichten zur
ukraine weil so feiert man den frau
sonntag ein mann redet und 20 frauen
hören zu aber keine von denen hat seinen
tee angerührt
im kreml würde ich auch nichts trinken
was man mir anbietet die armen frauen
oder und wenn sie zuhause sich jetzt
fragen wie begeht man denn in der
ukraine diesen frauen feiertag
anders
so putin jetzt hast du ein problem die
usa gegen sich aufbringen kann man
machen aber das sind mütter die
gefährlichste spezies der welt
unausgeschlafen und bewaffnet putin hat
dieses land und sein freiheitswillen
total unterschätzt und jetzt kriegt er
die quittung nicht nur militärisch auch
an der sanktions front apple hat
russland verlassen ikea mastercard visa
mcdonald's schließt vorübergehend alle
russischen filialen die folge riesige
schlangen am letzten tag weil die russen
natürlich angst haben dass ihr
cholesterinspiegel beide in den gesunden
bereich herunterrutschte und auch an der
entertainment front wird's bitter der
neue batman film läuft nicht in russland
und netflix hört auf dazu streamen und
macht ihn eben sein eigenes netflix
jetzt neu bei netflix
die neue daily soap nur mit vladimir
putin der sich putin immer in dieselbe
staatsform verliebt diktatur aber aber
gute diktatur route diktatur schlechte
diktatur oder unsere kult sitcom
wladimir putin erzählt staatsgästen an
einem absolut großen tisch dass er
garantiert nirgendwo einmarschieren will
lacht sich schlapp bei the big tisch
theorie
megafon
und für die kleinen mädels putin sonst
reise mit den wildgänsen da schreitet
uns erhält mit seinem propeller einen
schwarm ukrainischer nazi gänse plus
unvergessene kinohits wie der teufel
ließ
titanic putin und präsident sie bringen
mit ihrer liebe einen eisberg zum
schmelzen und ganz aktuell wladimir
putin als bergmann mit stargast olaf
scholz als joker
netflix
abonniert das oder es gibt 15 jahre
knast
top angebot viele sanktionen wie das mit
netflix eben oder leere supermarktregale
treffen natürlich die einfachen bürger
eigentlich wollten wir doch vor allem
putin und seine oligarchen treffen sie
wissen schon diese milliardäre die
putins macht stützen und mit ihm
zusammen seit jahren den russischen
rohstoffreichtum als persönliche beute
aufteilen müssen die jetzt befürchten
quasi abzustürzen in den millionärs rang
wäre natürlich eine demütigung wir
schalten live nach monte carlo zu
valeria in ears of ska sprecherin des
verbands der extrem klischeehaft
dargestellt und oligarchen frauen weil
er ja wie sehr treffen die sanktionen
ihre familie oder sie sehr nett dass sie
fragen denn im moment denkt niemand an
uns dabei sind auch wir in gewisser
weise flüchtlinge unsere kapital zum
beispiel die seit jahren auf der flucht
liegt der geburt ganz allein auf
irgendwelche offshore kunden in panama
klicken ihr besuch ich verzeihung ist
einfach sehr emotionale zeit gerade weil
ihr vermögen vielleicht eingefroren wird
nein aber wir müssen jetzt unser boot
auf den malediven bringen weil es da
nicht beschlagnahmt werden kann wie sie
was das kostet wenn sie nicht wahnsinnig
teuer geworden ich weiß gar nicht warum
und mein mann kann es nicht mal von der
steuer absetzen wolle keine steuern
zahlt aber da redet keiner drüber
stattdessen sind alle immer nur sauer
egal wo wir hinkommen mein mann und ich
zum beispiel wir haben ja ein haus am
tegernsee also näher das nicht und
daraus ist viel größer das ist jetzt nur
spieler aus von meine fünfjährige
tochter egal und da stehen neuerdings
immer so wütende leute davor mit
schildern und blau gelbe fahnen keine
ahnung sind dass schweden ich weiß es
nicht und die rufen wir sollen wegziehen
wegen putin ich meine da demonstrieren
nachbarn menschen aus diesem mar wie
heißt das dorf nach dieser favela am see
rottach egern genau am tegernsee und
schätzungsweise zehn russische
oligarchen und bis jetzt ist es dem
deutschen staat nicht gelungen irgendwas
zu beschlagnahmen oder einzufrieren gut
ab dafür gibt es einfache grund recke
dein stadt ist sehr dumm der kann ja
nicht mal nachweisen wenn was gehört
weil man uns erlaubt das über
briefkastenfirmen zu tarnen das hättet
ihr nicht machen sollen selbst alisher
usmanow darf seine drei häuser am see
behalten medien mogul und dicker kumpel
und putin wirklich ein sehr
sympathischer mann sieht man schon an
gesicht in hamburg reparieren sie gerade
seine jacht und die hat zwei
hubschrauberlandeplätze sehr praktisch
auf kriegt man ja besuch von zwei leute
mit hubschrauber wenn landet dann zuerst
wenn soldaten habe ich noch nie darüber
nachgedacht und auch diese yacht wurde
noch nicht beschlagnahmen mit anderen
worten die meisten oligarchen sanktionen
verpuffen total von wegen einer tut
richtig weh der ingenieur katzen verband
erklärt dass er keine in russland
gezüchteten katzen mehr registrieren
wird außerdem dürfen russische katzen
nicht mehr an schönheitswettbewerben
teilnehmen
und jetzt sage sie dass natascha in ihr
gesicht sagen sie ihr dass sie mich
schön genug ist für den internationalen
wettbewerb nur weil sie lucien ist das
kann ich nicht weil er ja nie aus ska
disclaimer kulturelle anordnung
die darstellerin in der gerade gezeigten
szene ist wieder russin noch oligarchen
das war auch gar nicht wirklich monte
carlo wir bitten dies zu entschuldigen
tja
putin hat uns wirklich eiskalt erwischt
wir haben gedacht in einer
globalisierten welt in der jeder mit
jedem handel treibt lässt sich auch
jeder konflikt aus räumen unter
erwachsenen aber was wenn einer gar
nicht mehr reden will und als einziges
recht dass der stärkeren akzeptiert
haben wir nie darüber nachgedacht und
plötzlich geht die angst um und man
google schlagworte wie schutzbunker
kleiner tipp ich würde es nicht google
das ergebnis zieht sie garantiert runter
andererseits die ängste sind ja real und
die meisten tipps dagegen helfen leider
nicht wirklich weiter und dann hilft es
einzuschätzen wie groß ist meine angst
am besten von 0 bis 100 wenn es über 70
ist dann helfen sogenannte skills das
heißt kaltes wasser ins gesicht auf
einer schiene schote kauen was sind das
denn schluss gilt das chili schote kauen
warum ich gleich den kopf in ventilator
halten das lenkt auch ab tatsächlich
haben wir den zivilschutz total
vernachlässigt der deutsche staat lager
zum beispiel viel zu wenig
sanitätsmaterial für große katastrophen
wir wollten halt über so deprimierende
sachen nicht mehr nachdenken zum glück
gibt es aber selbst für den atomkrieg
heutzutage youtube tutorials was würde
eigentlich passieren wir eine atombombe
auf der stadt geschlossen wird das zeige
ich euch ja generell muss gesagt werden
dass die erste maßnahme heißt
ja diesem ding ausweichen das erste was
ihr tut das allererste ist ihr nehmt
eure daumen und macht einen autozug die
erste sache ist ab auf den boden
herunter sofort auf den boden legen dann
daumen muss größer sein als diese
explosion oh mein gott das ist viel
größer als man dann bitte verpiss dich
sofort von ort und stelle
bleiben
warum sind es eigentlich immer nur
männer die solchen scheiß posten was
stimmt nicht mit uns inzwischen hat die
ampel übrigens angekündigt wieder mehr
in den schutz der bevölkerung zu
investieren da lob ich mir die heute
schon meine damen und herren wir haben
nämlich seit jahren einen eigenen
zivilschutz beauftragt und zwar
christian ehring christian schön dass du
da bist christi ab wie gut sind wir
vorbereitet auf sagen wir mal nuklearer
ernstfälle aller art sehr gut sehr sehr
gut also deutschland insgesamt leider
nicht so richtig gut aber keine angst
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen hat
bekanntlich jede sendung einen eigenen
bunker auch die heute show also nicht
für alle mitarbeiter die kameraleute
müsse ja weiter film das ist ja klar
aber ich sag mal für die wichtigen auf
jeden fall
ich stehe aber schon auf der liste oder
ja klar
insgesamt müssen wir wohl mehr machen
beim bevölkerungsschutz beispiel in der
schweiz gibt es für 100 prozent der
bürger einen bunker platz bei uns für 0
das ist wenig öffentliche bunker
fehlanzeige hat der bund fast alle
verkauft war im nachhinein vielleicht
nicht unsere beste idee ja aber was
macht man dann im worst case gute frage
dazu empfehle ich ihnen diesen
informationsfilme fenster schließen
jalousien bzw verdunklungs einrichtungen
herunterlassen elektrische geräte
ausschalten wasser gas und öl hähne
schließen
umgehend den schutzraum aussuchen
welchen schutzraum wir haben doch keine
ja sorry der film ist halt schon älter
und jetzt mit der neuen bedrohlichen
lage denkt der bund immerhin über ein
wiederaufbau von bunkeranlagen nach
dafür machen sie gerade eine
bestandsaufnahme die wohl ein paar
monate dauern wird und da appelliere ich
auch einfach mal an die fairness des
gegners so lange zu warten das wäre ein
gebot der höflichkeit
vor dem gespräch mit ihm habe ich mich
noch relativ sicher gefühlt und das
zurecht sie können sie sich freuen es
gibt überhaupt keinen grund zur panik ok
woran wir tatsächlich arbeiten sollten
das ist die sache mit den waren sirenen
der letzte bundesweite wahltag 2020 muss
uns da eine warnung sein der wahltag
ging also dank kaum vorhandener serien
technik und schlecht funktionierender
digitaler warnung diesmal am großteil
der bevölkerung vorbei also wir haben
nichts gehört twitter scherzhaft der
bund dec gehörlosen wobei fällt mir da
ein da wir ja gar keine bunker haben ist
es vielleicht auch besser den leuten
nicht unnötig mit sie reden hoffnungen
zu machen was futtern sie da
integriertes jodtabletten sie müssen
beim zeitunglesen er in der ukraine
beschließen sie atomkraftwerke und sie
müssen aufhören die zuschauer hier so
fit zu machen für die deutsche
bevölkerung besteht bei den entfernungen
praktisch kein risiko außerdem jeder
tabletten da die enthalten gerade einmal
0,2 milligramm jod um die schilddrüse
vor verstrahlung zu schützen dann
bräuchten sie 100 milligramm das wären
500 tabletten ach so wir sagen sie das
doch gleich und prophylaktisch fressen
ist ohnehin quatsch vor allem
erwachsenen ja wohl aber hier was ist
damit
können sie noch dass ein handy ots 11
ganz schön ich gehe nach hause christian
ehring
[Musik]
christian ehring ja trotz aller wut auf
putin wir kaufen weiter sein gas sein öl
seine kohle geschätzt eine milliarde
dollar überweisen eu-staaten dafür jeden
tag ist nicht schön aber geht nicht
anders sagt zum beispiel olaf scholz
auch robert habeck warnt vor einer
schweren wirtschaftskrise nach einem
embargo denn die preise für benzin und
diesel gehen in deutschland ja jetzt
schon durch die decke
zum glück greift der saarländische
ministerpräsident tobias tanz da jetzt
persönlich ein also greift da überhaupt
nicht ein aber er hat ein sehr schönes
populistisches handy video gedreht ich
bin jetzt hier gerade an der tankstelle
vorbei gefahren
ich finde da ist jetzt wirklich ein
punkt erreicht wo man sagen muss da muss
mal anderen das trifft jetzt wird nur
geringverdiener sondern das trifft
wirklich die fleißigen leute gedanken
müssen verstehen sie in deutschland gibt
es die fleißigen und die geringverdiener
ein fleißiger geringverdiener gibt es
nicht denn dann wären sie ja keine
geringverdiener meint tobias hans viel
glück im wahlkampf tatsächlich haben wir
in abhängigkeits problem rund ein
drittel unseres importierten öls kommt
aus russland die hälfte der steinkohle
in der stromerzeugung über die hälfte
des gases ja ja wir haben uns abhängig
gemacht von einem kriegsfilm psycho ist
das war nicht gut aber halt ihre
praktisch und preiswert eine zeit lang
außerdem haben wir deutschen ja auch
sachen die putin gerne hätte wären wir
radeberger ich liebe es angela schickt
mir ab und zu ein paar flaschen radeberg
agieren ja aber jetzt nicht mehr ganz so
schön die russische blogger saufen
gebraut aus terpentin und bären pässe
das berühmte krimbacher doch zurück zur
traurigen realität für die russische
kohle würden wir auf dem weltmarkt
irgendwie ersatz finden fürs öl übrigens
auch klar natürlich öl könnte man
genauso gut bei mir ankaufen des
jüngsten sympathischer start was auch
nicht dann nicht es gibt aktuell keine
schönen lösung mehr das ist die traurige
wahrheit in brunsbüttel bauen wir im
eiltempo ein terminal für flüssiggas
trotz mieser klimabilanz über doch
wieder längere laufzeiten
kohlekraftwerke wird diskutiert
einige könnte man zumindest in der
reserve halten plus natürlich die
debatte über atomkraft soll man die drei
verbleibenden akw es länger laufen
lassen oder nicht ganz ehrlich ich war
mir selber nicht sicher aber dann ist
mir die alte faustregel wieder
eingefallen einfach immer das gegenteil
von dem machen was dieser mann hier
fordert die atomenergie versuchen doch
gehe es nun darum aus ganz einfachen
gründen es ist billig es ist sicher die
energie und vor allen dingen sie ist
absolut klimafreundlich
erstens nein zweitens nein und drittens
auch nein warum streite ich eigentlich
mit hier mal abgesehen davon wie teuer
und gefährlich atomenergie in
wirklichkeit ist akw s haben spezielle
maßgeschneiderte brennelemente und die
neu besorgen dauert zb bei isa zwei mal
eben anderthalb jahre sagen selbst die
betreiber sie kriegt man nicht beim obi
in der brennelemente abteilung
preisfrage wie kommen wir runter von
unserer abhängigkeit vom russen stoff
wie geht das und geht das überhaupt die
experten von der leopoldina sagen diese
woche ein embargo sei zitat handhabbar
allerdings mit relativ heftigen folgen
für die deutsche wirtschaft oder ganz
andere idee wir passen uns an und wohnen
wenn es kalt wird halt woanders ja warum
denn nicht mitmachen doch andere tiere
auch
im reich der wilden tiere
es ist jedes jahr ein atemberaubendes
schauspiel 82 millionen zug deutsche
verlassen vor dem großen kälteeinbruch
ihr sommerdomizil und ziehen in südliche
gefilde
hier finden sie nahrung für ihre brut
und können sich ungestört der vermehrung
widmen da eine herde sachsen nähert sich
durstig dem wasserloch und dieser
possierliche schwabe erklärt
einheimischen in südfrankreich wie man
richtiges brot backt ihre eigentliche
heimat kann sich derweil etwas erholen
dorthin zurückkehren die zug deutschen
erst wieder im frühling pünktlich zur
spargelzeit
spargel ja vielleicht ist das die lösung
wir werden einfach alle zug deutsche die
wahrheit ist beim strom gibt
ausweichmöglichkeiten beim heizen würde
es allerdings eng sagen die fachleute
und im falle eines embargos könnte auch
unsere wirtschaft um circa drei prozent
schrumpfen ist nicht schön aber
andererseits na und dann muss der staat
hat noch mal richtig geld in die hand
nehmen zur stützung bestimmter branchen
einfach weitere sondervermögen wie
gerade erst für die bundeswehr da fällt
mir ein schlechtes über die bundeswehr
die energiewende managen lassen
stillgestanden für till reiners
stabsfeldwebel der allerletzten reserven
männer aber auch nicht mehr rührt euch
aufgepasst ab sofort kein deutsches geld
mehr für öl gas und kohle aus russland
und dann wenn ich jetzt kein gehören
leute verschenken panzerfäuste in die
ukraine und geben pudding gleichzeitig
geld für die panzer die mit dem
panzerfäusten abgeknallt werden mac oder
was das hört jetzt ab sofort auf ihr
lappen neuer tagesbefehl heizung nur
noch auf maximal 10 11 grad und daneben
drei pullover übereinander
wo ist das problem
die aktion heißt pulli start poti und
wenn ich jetzt einen von euch zivilisten
ohne fleecejacke erwische putzt er die
latrine mit der zahnbürste zweitens auf
deutschen autobahnen gilt das tempolimit
und zwar ab jetzt 130 fährt statt 160
spart 35 prozent benzin heißt ab tempo
131 ist man für putin und ein rottweiler
vaterlandsverräter der durchgehend 80
fährt kommt von mir persönlich den
friedensnobelpreis drittens und jetzt
wird es schmutzig aber so ist das eben
im krieg fracking ja liebe super egos 0
ließ dann müsst ihr jetzt durch meint
nicht erneuern rotbuschtee wir brauchen
übergangsweise auch fracking gas aus dem
ausland sagt sogar robert habeck hätte
ich die grünen gar nicht zugetraut für
ausrüstung für trekking und wenn jetzt
noch toni hofreiter einen schönen
bürstenhaarschnitt verpassen werde ich
die beim nächsten mal geht mir aber noch
nicht weit genug ich will deutsches
fracking gas ja deutschland muss mal
wieder richtig durch gefragt werden wir
sitzen auf gas für zehn jahre bei der
produktion entstehen zwar ohne ende
treibhausgase aber irgendwas ist halt
immer letzter punkt energiewende
genehmigungsverfahren für windräder
werden verkürzt auf 3 minuten max sowie
bei uns in der kaserne nach 18 uhr
genehmige ich mir auch schnell mal
deutschlands größte wir sind wir noch
den spaß rakete übrigens auch die
einzige die funktioniert andere
geschichte wir wollen jetzt in jedem
vorgarten 100 jede bürgerinitiative der
das nicht passt kann gerne unterstütze
machen und kommt mir jetzt bloß nicht
mit irgendwelchen büchern
aber bei uns in der region leicht die
seltene gelbbauchunke wirklich das ist
ja toll
eine seltene gelbbauchunke
problem gelöst nec treten
till reiners aktuell waren unsere
geheimdienste wieder vor cyber angriffen
durch profi hacker in putins diensten
wie damals erinnern sich 2015 beim
großen datenklau im bundestag also beim
bundestags heck kritische infrastruktur
ist akut gefährdet im moment aber auch
deutsche banken als rache für sanktionen
ist wirklich eine spannende frage wie
wehrhaft sind wir deutschen im cyberraum
der seilbahn ist zunächst einmal keine
physische dimension
das ist richtig aber gerade nicht
relevant es gibt in seiner krieg und den
allgemeinen infokrieg russland arbeitet
seit jahren mit hilfe von gezielter
desinformation an der spaltung der
europäischen gesellschaften und ich sag
mal an der front hat nicht zuletzt rt
deutsch ganze arbeit geleistet auch wenn
der zuletzt ein sendeverbot
ausgesprochen wurde und wenn sie mal
hören möchten was jahrelang rt deutsch
konsum so anrichtet in dem gehirn dann
können sie eigentlich zu jeder
beliebigen querdenker demo gehen
wirklich verlaufen ohne ende putin fans
herum und haben den totalen durchblick
ja behaupten kann an der 17 menschen
zweiter klasse sind sollen im moment
sind die russen die menschen zweiter
klasse wir wissen das ja dass das den
hintergrund schieben wir nicht in eure
normale die natur menschen das dass die
eigentliche ursache ist das was wir als
kommune und foto flib bekommen
präsentiert bekommen und da hat und
ihnen gesagt jetzt ist schluss mit neue
weltordnung
das haben wir doch ganz schön
herausgearbeitet wir zuschauer ja finde
ich auch das klang für mich alles
absolut schlüssig was weist die theorie
olaf scholz will von seiner impft
diktatur ablenken also ruft er bill
gates an und sagte alter kinder blut
trinker ich muss mal dringend schon was
ablenken du kein problem sagt will ich
rufe im putin an lade mir alles fit du
könntest du bitte mal kurz die ukraine
angreifen geht um eine ablenkung ja klar
mach ich glaube du bist der beste
ja wie denn jetzt putin ist der held der
querdenker aber gleichzeitig hilft hat
bei der im stück natur meine nix gegen
irrsinn aber es muss schon eine innere
logik haben ja das kommt davon wenn man
glaubt was russische trolle schreiben an
dieser berüchtigten petersburger
torfabrik was arbeiten wir so viele
leute und woran genau
ganz europa als struktur wird von uns
als potenzieller feind gesehen europa
ist stabil aber wir brauchen keinen
stabilen nachbarn bevor du anfängst dort
zu arbeiten musst du einen vertrag
unterschreiben du wirst dann einen
lügendetektor angeschlossen
und sie ahnen es nur wenn du bei allen
fragen und lügt wie gedruckt kriegst du
den job bei denen wobei es manchmal ja
gar keine echten menschen sind die
unsere internet foren zumüllen oft sind
es ja bekanntlich maschinen man liest
dann was diese boards schreiben und
denkst du liebe güte wir sind ja ganz
schön gestalten als gesellschaft am ende
soll keiner mehr irgendetwas glauben
darum geht es der russische staat lässt
hecken durch staatliche hacker wie
zuletzt in der ukraine wo er angegriffen
wurde und tut dann hinterher so als
hätte er nichts damit zu tun hacker sind
freie menschen sie sind wir künstler
wenn ein künstler sich morgens gut fühlt
dann malte den ganz tag das gleiche gilt
für hacker die hacken dann den ganzen
tag sind künstler künstler eben man
legten krankenhaus lahm und dann hat man
vielleicht aschenbecher je nachdem wie
man sich fühlt leider ist das alles
nicht künstlerisch wertvoll sondern
brandgefährlich denn bei
hacker-angriffen können obendrein
schwere kollateralschäden entstehen
neulich haben zum beispiel mutmaßliche
russische hacker einen satelliten
netzwerk angegriffen dass die ukraine
mit internet versorgt und dieser angriff
hatte sehr konkrete folgen auch bei uns
in deutschland
5800 windkraftanlagen der auricher firma
enercon sind von dem angriff betroffen
die anlagen sind zwar in betrieb und der
zeugen strom eine steuerung per
fernzugriff ist aber aktuell unmöglich
wir hatten die kontrolle über die
windräder verloren die fernbedienung hat
nicht mehr funktioniert
vorsicht
so ähnlich war es genau wegen der gefahr
solcher kollateralschäden verzichtet
deutschland als demokratie und
rechtsstaat selber auf cyberangriffe in
anderen ländern solche angriffe werden
bei uns lediglich abgewehrt zum beispiel
im nationalen cyber-abwehrzentrum in
bonn und genau da schalten wir jetzt mal
hin zu alexander wipprecht er wipprecht
wie ist die lager der cyber front
angespannter welke wir rechnen jetzt
hier jeden tag mit russischen attacken
auf deutsche hoch wer ziele also
krankenhäuser kraftwerke zdf
fernsehgarten und leider dürfen wir
nicht zurück hecken appell
koalitionsvertrag seite 16 hacks lehnen
wir grundsätzlich ab schade wenn es nach
mir ginge könnte sich der putin gerne
blicken aber
technisch können wir da schon mithalten
oder ja klar ich bete ist hier bei uns
in der behörde ist das internet sogar
richtig schnell gutes darf nicht
gleichzeitig eine auf dem festnetz
telefonieren das ist klar stefan
jütte auf wir sind jetzt ein verdammt
noch mal
ja darf man nicht vergessen wir waren ja
mal federführend also einer der
allerersten hacker überhaupt war einer
von uns fischer strände was
ich bin trennen
er war damals sicher oft drin und
deswegen zeigt er bis heute
andere geschichte hier herrscht erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft
wir haben für die server abwehr gerade
erst die besten jungen hacker
eingekaufte den strom zum beispiel
direkt aus dem darknet abgekommen da die
street geht für den cyberspace gehoben
wir haben wir schon darüber gesprochen
dass das du vielleicht einen
arbeitsplatz ein kleines bisschen
hygienischer die fresse du bist nicht
mein vater
klar wir sehen uns aber
jetzt zeige ich ihnen mal was richtig
cooles herweck wir haben uns gefragt wer
wäre eigentlich die perfekte geheimwaffe
gegen diese verbrecher in der
petersburger torfabrik und dann ist es
uns eingefallen
deutsche händler hier die zwei die
ketten jetzt schon den ganzen tag mit
den trollen und verwickeln sie in so
klassische oper computer gespräche
wissen sie zufällig wie mein e mail
passwort heißt mist ich habe aus
versehen auf f2 geklickt jetzt ist alles
weg bei mir steht jetzt ob daten hier so
ein pop up fans ruhig denn dieses da die
fragen mich ob ich härtere erektion will
muss ich da drauf klicken verstehen sie
betreiben wir petersburg nach und nach
in den wahnsinn die operation läuft
unter dem kunden haben alle gegend rolle
aha und was machen sie sonst so bis
feierabend
alles mögliche klar häckseln verboten
aber wer sagt denn dass wenig
aufregendes richtung russland schicken
dürfen schauen sie mal das berühmte
angeber foto von wladimir putin mit
diesem riesen hecht das hat meine
photoshop leute jetzt in einem
aufwendigen verfahren über monate so
bearbeitet achtung
dass der fisch volk eine
peinliche schicken wir jetzt mal direkt
in den kreml und zwar per fax moment das
gehoben wie war nochmal die vorfahrt von
moskau halt die fresse
alexander wipprecht live aus dem cyber
abwehrzentrum in bonn
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt